All right, so I have a perfect video clip for
you today to illustrate one of the biggest ruses
that exists on Fox News in the past when Fox
News has been criticized for their outrageous,
cartoonish right wing political bias,
they'll often say, listen, we have our
opinion programing just like any other network.
And sure, some of it is is right wing. It's
conservative, it's pro-Republican. But we are
also a news station. And during news hours,
we are right up there with the best of them and
reporting just the facts, just the news. Now,
without even looking at today's clip, which I'm
going to get to in a moment. Understand that Fox
News deliberately has blurred the lines between
news and opinion for a very long time, for as
long as they've existed. And also not that this
is their fault. Due to terrible media literacy
in the United States, much of their audience
doesn't realize what is news and what is opinion.
Fox News also does something where they will
report on what their opinion hosts say during the
news hours as if it's news. So, Tucker Carlson,
one night might say something insane on his 9:00
p.m. show. And then the next day, the news hours
will have a news report about Tucker Carlson said
this. Here's a panel to discuss it. So even they
are able to take their own opinion programing and
put it directly into the news segments. So this
news versus opinion distinction has been nonsense
from day from day one. But then we have this
clip to play of news. A reporter, Bill Hemmer,
from the news reporting side of Fox News during a
news, not opinion show called America's NEWSROOM,
saying, we've got to be careful with this
council culture stuff because the next thing
you know, they're going to cancel Bible
characters. Take a look at the video clip.
I tell you, if they start canceling these American
presidents, they're going to come after Bible
characters next. Yeah, you could
you mark my words. Wow. Yeah, right.
An ominous warning from Bill Hemmer that the
canceled culture liberals are going to cancel
Bible characters if we allow them to continue.
For some reason, the inclusion of Mark my words
at the end is particularly hysterical. I was sort
of chuckling to myself because as ridiculous and
silly as this is, at least Bill Hemmer is
calling them Bible characters rather than
historical figures. Now, I don't know if that's
his intention. I don't know if we can read too
much into his perspective from it. But it is funny
and this is lowest common denominator type stuff.
This is what happens when you aren't a victim and
your audience aren't victims, at least in the ways
they claim to be. Much of the Fox News audience
are victims of deficits to our educational system,
victims of the power of elites and corporations.
And so, OK, fine, but they're not victims in the
ways they claim to be victims. And the political
interests that they represent aren't victims
either. They invent a new victimhood. The war
on Christmas was the fabrication of victimhood.
Donald Trump as the most unfairly treated person
in the world or whatever it was he claimed to be,
that's fabricating victimhood with Trump.
It was almost like fabricating martyrdom
even. And then the saddest, most horrifying
part of it is that a significant portion of
the country, I don't know the percentage, but
it's a significant number, sees this and says,
yep, that resonates with me. That's a concern
of mine. That's the battle. That's my battle
that Fox News is waging here that feels
like something really important. They might
cancel Bible characters and it ends up being
the horrible situation that we have. Of course,
the entire cancelation meme that they won't stop
with is as pathetic as any specific example,
but they've started to get attention with the
council culture stuff. And so they're going to
write it for as long as they can. Let's do our
best not to fall for it. There are some people
on the left who fall for the council culture
stuff. And of course, we can all find instances of
wrongful termination or misapplication of terms
of service on a platform. But let's not feed into
this false notion that everything is just unfairly
canceling conservatives who merely want to
get their opinions out there. No, we've talked
about it before. I'm glad to rehash it again,
if necessary. That is not what is going
on here. We shouldn't allow ourselves
to feed the notion because they will just take it.
And this is what you end up with. I'll tell you,
they're going to cancel Bible characters if we
let them keep doing it. No, it's not happening